básicamente lo que está tratando de
hacer el ex presidente Donald Trump es
crear un problema magnificar el tema que
usted mencionaba de la inflación el tema
de los precios de la gasolina de la
inseguridad de la crisis migratoria
magnificar esto decir que Estados Unidos
está pasando por su peor momento en la
historia que nunca había estado tan mal
que está siendo completamente destruido
por la administración de jovajin y sus
decisiones para después entonces
plantearse como una figura mesiánica y
pues tratar de Resaltar sin pruebas Sin
evidencia de que Estados Unidos nunca
había estado mejor como lo ha repetido
varias veces en este discurso que cuando
estaba con él que el país miró hizo un
cambio completamente radical de cómo era
hace dos años cuando él estaba en el
poder y cómo es ahora se refirió a temas
de temas de seguridad temas migratorios
de hecho hizo mención a la comunidad
latina que de hecho fue la que le dio
gran una gran votación al partido
republicano no solamente para elegir a
el gobernador rondy santis eventual
contrincante de Donald Trump en la
carrera por la por la candidatura
republicana sino también al senador que
se quiso reelegir marco Rubio que
seguirá entonces en el senado en el ex
presidente Donald Trump Precisamente en
cuanto a las elecciones de medio término
Pues también hizo mención que los
candidatos que él respaldó que muchos de
ellos ganaron esto a pesar de que como
lo hemos visto en carreras claves como
la gobernación por Arizona como la el
senado y la gobernación en Pensilvania
donde se definían estos estados que son
péndulos y que podrían marcar el rumbo
político del país los candidatos que él
apoyó como dogmas triano como el doctor
Oz pues perdieron sus carreras al senado
y a la gobernación de Pensilvania y
recientemente hoy conocimos que las
candidatas Lake también en Arizona
perdió su supuesto para la gobernación
de su estado que era clave porque ella
decía que iba a cambiar todo el tema
electoral toda la legislación electoral
de ese estado que pues es que que ha
definido las elecciones pasadas No
solamente en el 2020 sino en estas
elecciones de medio término Trump en
muchas ocasiones repitió que el país
estaba en una crisis y que él lo iba a
salvar y que por eso se lanzaba a la
presidencia para salvar el país de la
izquierda radical liderada por Joe biden
y su equipo de gobierno que están
llevando según él el país en el declive
sin embargo le doy una un dato que
además publica un medio que es más de
tendencia conservadora a Boca de uno en
la boca de urna en las elecciones de
medio término que fueron la semana
pasada se le preguntó a muchos
estadounidenses que pensaban de el
trabajo que había hecho Donald Trump
como presidente de la opinión que le
merecía el ex presidente en este momento
y según tejido del medio de tendencia
más conservadora el 58% de los
estadounidenses secuestrados dijo que la
imagen del presidente era desfavorable
que lo que estaba haciendo era
desfavorable y radicalizando y no
desconociendo los resultados de
presidenciales del 2020 Y pues el 39%
dijo que todavía era favorable Donald
Trump todavía tiene bastante poder sobre
todo en esta ala más radical en su
partido republicano todavía tiene mucha
atención mediática como se ve en este
momento con el cubrimiento al menos
nacional que se le está haciendo todos
los medios de comunicación en Estados
Unidos están cubriendo este y cubrieron
estas Este anuncio de Donald Trump de
lanzamiento Y pues quiere aprovechar
este este cuarto de hora que tiene este
todavía está presencia mediática que
tiene para restar la importancia a
futuros contrincantes como son el
gobernador ru que sí que muchos medios
de comunicación conservadores ya lo
perfilan como un candidato presidencial
y como su vicepresidente Mike pence que
se que ha sido ahora una figura de
oposición a Donald Trump y que puede ser
también una ficha bastante importante
que le puede generar Pues un contrapeso
bastante fuerte para esta carrera su
reelección en el 2024